and there you have it folks the
microsoft press conference here at e3
2015 what a show there was a lot of
stuff that got us all here clamoring in
the war room at gamespot HQ we are going
to run through all of it so stick with
us here we're gonna share our
impressions our hopes our dreams for the
things that we saw and stuff that really
impressed us so guys we're gonna start
off right where we thought they would
start off halo 5 Guardians kicked off
the microsoft press conference and they
showed some four player co-op campaign
play showed some trailers what you guys
think I thought was fantastically did a
great job of a halo 5 I think that they
knew that game needed to be different
enough and I think they'd be emphasized
what was going to be knew about this
game I think with the war zone
multiplayer at the end that they showed
I think that's going to be really
interesting I think the cynic and people
are going to say okay they're adding a
bit of titanfall in there they're adding
bit of Destiny in there but personally I
think they've done a really good job I
think it's looking way more distinct
than previous Halo games there was
always like a common like thread between
each of them where's this feels like 343
kind of ripping it away from Bungie and
making it of its own halo 4 was a small
step towards up but it still was very
much tied into the old thing but by
pushing most achieve on to the other
side and having a brand new group of
people to kind of look after its really
really interesting I like that I mean we
were reading about the four player co-op
stuff beforehand by like that we got to
see that in action and it looked really
cool where lock was giving orders to
different people and they were kind of
doing as he was told as they were told
it look really really cool I'm excited
about it it still feels like halo though
because you got meaner than that that
grunt spot was the perfect hailer spot
for me I regret exactly it was adorable
it still got that I don't know that that
little bit of it to me like that little
bit of humor or that and plus lots of
purple purpose my halo color purple and
yellow so it's both oh hello and you hit
a contrast I really do like that four
player co-op dynamic they're showing off
the banter reminded me of ODST of reach
and those are some of bungees more
personality driven halos and so I'm
definitely looking forward to those
characters being fleshed out the new
Promethean sort of the hunter hunter
killers at the inator
is there ice or two new Promethean
enemies on display here yeah as well as
the Spartan abilities from the
multiplayer beta and like we just saw
there is a lot more cooperation between
characters like we saw the one of the
Spartans reviving another one which is
something new to the series and it is
like it's very similar to stuff like
gears and other co-op based games like I
think in when you're playing on your own
you can issue a command to one of the AI
characters to go and do it whereas
whether you're playing with an actual
human you can go over and do it yourself
so yeah and there's a bit towards the
end where the actual the main boss enemy
that came up comes up at the ground and
it looks just like destiny so it's like
it felt like a destiny moment there yeah
wow yeah they're kind of drawing from
all of its all the inspirations and were
like where the halo has gone gone on to
become way to become different games
that they're taking everything so yeah
it is looking very very cool i like i
like the look of it so far i'm excited
for halo once again after somewhat tepid
response to halo 4 and halo 5 Guardians
due out this fall I they announce
release date is an October release date
I Blanco currently yeah I think that I
guess I was just so hyped by I didn't
know I was just rolling off my chair
October 27 halo 5 Guardians all right
next up we have I they showed us their
classic their pillar of the the sort of
old IPS next up we have a new IP recore
what do you guys think I thought it
looked fantastic I reminded me of I go
insane moments you know that the
isolation you against the world I really
like this idea that your companion in
this we thought it's gonna be a dog cuz
most games have dogs these days right
and it was a dog for most of the trailer
yeah but it was actually in all but
right it would it's all a digital soul
you can put in two different machines I
thought it was a really cool idea I
think the development talent behind this
is fantastic and I think it's got a lot
of promise yeah development sound being
keiji inafune a and the creators of ma
metroid prime yes that's armature
Studios which is the kind of some of the
developers from Metroid Prime retro who
recently made a batman arkham origins
blackgate for
via NPS laurens that kind of stuff and
they've also done a lot of port work on
metal gear solid and a whole bunch of
other games so they have got a pedigree
to them I mean Blackgate wasn't a
massive success and it wasn't exactly
amazing didn't set the world on fire
they did trade off a lot of that metroid
prime metroid kind of history but i'm
looking forward to seeing what they did
with something a little more original
and it's good to see in a funny working
on something else again could I just ask
Oh a whiny question if you're a backer
of concepts new platformer game was my
number 9 my number nine if you were a
backer of mighty number 9 and you know
that in a few nay is now working on
something else before the yeah before
the final development of that game how
would you feel I don't know I think a
lot of people might be savvy enough to
know that his his part of designing
might be over by that point and glam but
then again he's a guy that worked at
capcom on a whole bunch of games at once
i mean he had his fingers in so many
pies a cup command a lot of those games
came out and they were excellent so he's
a guy that's clearly capable of working
on multiple projects at the same time
he's just not done it since he was at
capcom you know because she's not been
at a studio that big but as concept
continues to grow i reckon he'll start
moving back into that role fair enough
maybe I was being a bit too cynical
Bella you know well balanced Nobel right
at the end there with recore of course
you saw a sort of a tease of some of the
other sort of animal like shapes that
the orb will be able to inhabit there
was a gorilla kind of floating octopus
spider creepy and so you know definitely
some some gameplay diversity maybe you
can extrapolate from that but recore one
of the big surprises of microsoft's e3
2015 press conference looking very cool
from recore we headed into the biggest
one of the biggest bombshell quotes of
perhaps of this e3 your xbox 360 games
will be playable natively on your xbox
one Megaton Megaton is huge that is
absolutely huge incredibly infuriating
silly i just put all those games away I
think this is a fantastic initiative by
Microsoft it really is going to win a
lot of fans over everyone and their
brother have an xbox 360 right every
one has that everyone has a massive
collection of xbox 360 game my sister's
even got an xbox your sister has an
expert you have everyone hello so you
know I think it's a great idea there was
a great dig at Sony because and I think
it looked quite deserves one because
PlayStation now is streamed games that
we already own like a price you know and
they said you could play your old game
for free on xbox one that was a big
shots fired there there's some shots
fired you we won't charge you to play
games you already own a lot so that of
course raises the question how ya can't
imagine them being like yup yeah because
they say okay you have your your disc
put the disc in download it to your xbox
one and then you can play but you can't
imagine them just letting anyone with a
game disc use it cuz then pass you
around use rental market becomes a whole
different day and you could just pass it
around and I don't know it's that's the
kind of a free license that platform
holders have been really reluctant to
give up in this generation of consoles
however they were also reluctant to talk
about any kind of backwards
compatibility and now we're seeing it
implemented so what do you guys think
how surprising how far Microsoft's come
from trying to lock down like the
pre-owned market to this point way seems
like they just completely reverse those
compare this bleep I get the feeling
that there's going to be some caveats
that they just don't want to dig into
because it would kind of a disagreement
I think I think they're going to be open
about I think I'm gonna be totally cool
about it I definitely think they're
gonna detail and they're going to be
open about it but I think they don't
want to go into the nitty gritties wear
one every CD has every game has a unique
code that wanted to use is gone like
they don't want to talk about that
because they think is that they're not
gonna make any money on backwards
compatibility this is never gonna be
about money i mean it up sells the xbox
one slightly yes but this is this is
about fanservice right this is about
their engineers doing loads of software
emulation on the back end so we can play
old games this isn't about selling or do
you recognize everyone will be able to
just pass around the same game and yeah
i think that's going to be actually fine
i think a few publishers who would
re-releasing digital deluxe editions
gonna be a bit annoyed that the
originals are now that'll be available
on this one or they might just not make
them available because they said it's
not generous it's not going to require
any more development to make the it
work but it does require dev approval
right so I or yeah well oh yeah the game
developers or you know whoever happens
to own that bro license needs to approve
it it's not just let's put everything
out there so it was a bit like share
play where Sony was like oh this is
gonna be great you can just track you
can play games online of your friends
all the time and then every publisher
went now you know you're not doing yeah
very really interesting to see how
that's going to work out that's xbox one
backwards compatibility with the xbox
360 Wow big huge uh then we've got a
look at the elite controller mm-hmm the
xbox elite controller what did you guys
I I was running a new story time so I
was kind of looking up and down and
basically every time I looked up the
controller was just like in bits I'm not
completely sure what's happening if
someone's gonna blame ya the domed
analog stick for the concave one if you
want or the d-pad I think was the most
sort of eye-catching is that uh that
like little Basin that had a different
angles so it was again it was like a
little hole to sort of our cave to rest
your thumb in and then move around from
there I'll be really happy if either i
have some kind of other bumpers that i
can stick in there or some bumper
alternative because the bumpers are the
thing I hate the most on the xbox one
controller oh right I so I would really
love to get something in there but I
think also something to note was they it
says compatible with xbox one and
Windows 10 like right there on the
screen son of a takes a shine off
Microsoft's know microsoft's esteems new
controller right if it's kind of got
like it looks like for example that bit
day it looks like almost like a mouse
pad area and so if it could do if they
could add that kind of functionality
into it it could kind of cross over and
let make it more to it for pc play i am
slightly amazed that if you could make
any but personally if i could make any
modification to the xbox one controller
i would add in lithium batteries or like
yeah recharge abilities happy but this
appears to be a lot of battery case very
casing here they're going hard on Barry
casing it does look I mean there's gonna
be a lot of third-party you know
peripheral makers out there creating
custom bits and it's a good way to
customize your own control
like I do you know people love buying
the halo version of a control if they
could just released like a halo you know
d pad or something like that it's a good
way to inform Microsoft and for
peripheral makers to make you money and
give people a chance to express
themselves through their control
yourself don't just put a sticker on it
cuz they rub off I also it's got those
tabs on the back you ever play with a
controller with these things because
they're definitely in use in competitive
circles yeah because it's a way to get
more button access without taking your
thumb off the analogues to press the
buttons I you know I don't have you
tried it I've never tried I mean the
last time I saw something like that was
when call of duty hacking is a big thing
and people adding in shortcuts in the
back just so they can do weird like 360
noscopes and that kind of stuff but I
was extra buttons that's where that's
how I could do it tomorrow I knew it I
do with all this time but yeah I've
never used by me I'm definitely
intrigued like it opens up the with like
more strategy games arriving and that
kind of thing it could open up a lot of
possibilities with shortcuts and that
kind of thing programmable buttons so
yeah it's definitely interesting right
on xbox elite controller for xbox one
and Windows 10 coming sometime uh then I
feel like we entered a little bit of a
lull in rest conference cuz we went to
that fallout 4 demo and don't get me
wrong I'm very excited for Fallout 4 but
the demo at Bethesda's press conference
last night was so much more expansive
yeah I todd howard was so much more
animated uh this just felt like a lesser
version so what was the point yeah he
was not quite sure why this happened
yeah I don't know yeah I mean they
announced the the fallout 3 coming with
fallout 4 I got one on xbox one side
well then they also talked about mods
yeah I think maybe that was the big
story here is that mods created on the
pc can be shared on xbox one and I mean
you guys have all seen plenty of mods in
your day for a Skyrim for GTA but for
fallout 3 there's some for fallout 4 the
mind reels at how many moms can bring on
the pipe especially given the
customization we saw on display and
fallout 4 last night during Bethesda's
press yeah I'm actually I should be a
bit more positive about this because i
think pc modding
being able to be being able to play that
on the Xbox one I think that's going to
be a big deal again I think it
strengthens that that link between the
xbox one Windows 10 which Microsoft is
showing so much the moment and you know
I think it's pretty good move it's a
pretty big deal for bethesda as well
like let's not forget yesterday they
announce something similar for doom with
the first in it as well so they do play
nap now yeah snap map and Bethesda net
which is powering a lot of their online
presence for from forums to actual like
user-generated content propagation that
kind of stuff so it's it's it's
interesting I like that because it's
kind of going back to its PC roots in an
element for some of these franchises and
allowing people to come together I think
it's strengthening the community which
is good because a lot of these games
they rely on people generating coming
together and like after a while like
fallout becomes you once you've played
fallout a bunch of times like it kind of
been stagnates and you kind of like
playing the stuff over and over again
but if they're given though people to
come the opportunity to come together
and keep keep it fresh it's just it just
works out good for them when they
release like extra content officially
then people will be already there I just
wonder how far it goes or who the
gatekeepers are for some of this because
I think of using something like even
even with Skyrim and using the neck you
know the Nexus stuff and all that stuff
like you can easily just break [ __ ] all
over the place and you go wrong yeah
there's a whole lot that could go wrong
when you do mod so I kind of wonder
who's gonna be the gatekeeper these
things gonna need to be approved it's
just gonna open up the whole you know
paid mods you know can of worms all over
again you know what do that what are
they going to do to be keeping us from
you know I don't know how many people
are prepared to break their copy of
fallout 4 on a console so first thing
was interesting point that point that
Kevin made when they tried to introduce
steam mods mods for Skyrim and there was
a lot of backlash and Bethesda said that
may be introducing it with a community
that was pre-existing will fall with a
Skyrim was a bad idea so this might be
an opportunity to redo that stuff again
yeah from the outset and make paid mods
a thing it is kind of a start from
scratch situation not just because it's
a new game but because you're also
talking about the console yeah
transferability and you know sort of
creating and starting to create that mod
community to more you were talking about
on a console it's going to be really
interesting to see how this works out
as we look ahead to the release of
fallout 4 this November November 10 yeah
and then from there we talked some EA
access ok titanfall coming to a dragon
age inquisition yay access is free to
all gold members this week which means
nothing to us who are stranded in LA
without the consoles but I don't know
anything here substantive to you guys
EXO I mean time fall kind of it burn
bright but in porn for very long that's
one and it was I mean in the last
Microsoft sale remember is going for
just a few like pounds and and the dlc
was like yeah as well our yeah kind of
yeah you know what even though it looks
a bit desperate it's actually Reese
mummy case the main thing that they need
right now is a community yeah big
community of players who want your bum
playin it keep on talking about it and I
think that's what they're losing and I
think that's why they're giving away for
free now you're talking about titanfall
specifically here because we know a new
titan falls in the works respawns not at
e3 this year though so we're not going
to be hearing anything about that
however yeah keep to keep titanfall and
players minds as I remember that yeah
yeah uh then we went to a game that I
was like a game that I was delighted to
see but maybe drew a few sort of uh
plants vs zombies garden warfare to
anybody hey hey guys num no bigger than
anybody oh I I think that's why I mean
they look charming it look cool I I
guess I could go back I want to go back
and pay the original but yeah do that
there's a single coming out at some
point I'm not cute that was a fun one
and it's one of these that like during a
press conference is really delightful to
just see the like saturated colors and
like playfulness which will definitely
get to later as we talk about the indie
showcase and of course rares appearance
but before we get there uh judging from
our pre-show I'm guessing that nut not a
lot of us have a lot to say about
fortson motorsport six not really it's a
racing game so ratio the ratio every
college I can see we all know more full
wheels on every single crikes two doors
either side go up and down well there
was a lot more going up down on that car
than just on every vehicle was ever been
in for its up but it was a bit weird
moment when they was
before six because they were lowering a
car into it I was I just kind of want is
gonna fall but no assassin that's a
headline right there freak accident car
but you know Ford pays millions and
damages well I just wish they had Dan
Greenawalt then step out of that that's
get me a Peter more tolerable level
approximation of stunt you know
executive stunt kind of thing but what
do they expect people to do right now
okay oh my god oh my god is a car yeah
they expect you to do the same thing
with this car that you did with the
trailer algal the cars they damn those
cars look good oh cool the cars are
gonna happen lady but speaking of ugly
as soon as I think that the the first
frame of this trailer came up we all
knew what it was dark souls 3 yep our
first look here I would be you guys they
show Dark Souls 3 this is what it looked
like right from the bonfire yeah you got
on the beginning produced by Bandai
Namco in that text everyone gasped
everyone was excited yeah I got that
sort of a mud-born dragging a body
around do you ever even drag bodies in
that game and he was dark souls 3 not
announced in terms of like exclusivity
this or that but this was our first look
at it Kevin you are something of a fan
of the Dark Souls serious thing what do
you say about Dark Souls 3 i'm hyped but
I mean what is there to say right now we
have this little teaser trailer yeah and
not a whole and it giant Knight Rises
yeah but not a not a whole lot beyond
that I mean this looks very dark soul so
for me it's gonna be a question of
upsetting it's gonna be a question of
setting gonna like what I'm gonna be in
this sort of dark fantasy world there's
your Simon there's a lot of similarities
between the first two dark souls obvious
or it's got the usual like callbacks you
know it's got the crown a kingdom that
snow fallin and you know there's going
to be a kind of struggle or you know
it's always surrounding like power
struggles and what happened to this
kingdom where is the monarch that kind
of thing and obviously like some sort of
demon scourge or uprising happening on
the time
hey it looks it looks very similar to
original doctors we haven't seen a lot
of the new stuff obviously there was
that leaked earlier which suggested a
lot of crazy things like you know
sacrifices and that kind of stuff but
we've got this huge thing here and
another thing to know huge place another
thing to note which is really important
in the leaked or the rumors earlier
there was talk of miyazaki being
involved in this version not confirmed
in this at all that's ram he is
currently believed to be working on
blood-borne dlc so we don't know quite
what he's doing now it may be that he's
actually left blood-borne and doing
something else we're not quite sure when
you first heard that rumor you were very
doubtful word yeah I was doubtful about
my uncle because he's the kind of guy I
mean fans of souls really dig into you
know what how Miyazaki is as a person
and he's the kind of guy that when he
has a project he really focuses in on
that Roy I mean he was known for being
quite involved in the dlc for original
Dark Souls and and that kind of thing so
it would strike me as very unusual if he
abandoned dog shows to work on something
and sorry blood-borne to work on
something else I reckon he would put a
full stop to blood-borne before he moved
on but having said that I mean the team
from software has grown significantly as
you can see they're working on two
products at the same time so it may be
the case that he's kind of delegated to
his his you know underlings all
second-in-command removing his
underlings he's luring years opinion he
wears the crown so you know he's like
make me a game so it may be um he could
come out soon I think Sony would want to
keep a lid on whether he's involved
right now because a lot of blood bones
you know is being sold off people are
reacting to the fact that it's a
Miyazaki game you know there was a lot
of backlash against dark souls 2 even
though it's a good game like people were
saying that we can tell that he wasn't
involved in this so for him to bounce
this early from blood-borne would be a
bit weird for a lot of fans in the
series but still it looks good I'm
enjoying I enjoyed what I saw of it
evoked the similar themes and vibes from
the original Dark Souls and Dark Souls 2
so I'm excited I'm always up for another
Souls game oh yeah yeahs Souls game dark
souls 3 come down the pipe at some time
did they say early 2016 in any of the
trailer so look forward to that next
year now uh you be so Ubisoft took the
stage
they did at the microsoft press
conference this year and even with their
own press conference coming later this
afternoon they showed off two games the
first of which was the division of
course this one we've sort of it's been
a few III s running now that we've been
getting looks at this and this one
seemed to focus on the people you know
talking about be we activate we thought
this was gonna happen they've told us
this might happen we prepared you know
we were prepared for when everything we
knew would just stop happening and yet
being activated inting at the lure of
who are these people who when society
goes bad just start walking around with
assault rifles and trying to restore
order I always I always got the
impression what I felt like they were
going for a kind of like minimal law
thing just create a world and allow
people to create the stories within it
in the same way that something like
Daisy does but it seems like and it's
not really surprising considering the
Tom Clancy series is based on quite
heavy narrative-driven stuff it's quite
like interesting that they're going for
an actual story to tell when the
gameplay is kind of like open world go
around create gangs and find stuff so
yeah it looks good though I really
enjoyed what I saw so far yeah and I
think that you know you talk about a
game like Daisy or these games with more
emerging narratives those are sort of
heavily dependent on a multiplayer
component on there being dynamic sort of
elements people creating their own
stories we certainly see in this trailer
that there are a lot of gas masked thugs
who are very like very clearly visually
read as enemy however in years past
we've also seen uh competing squads
human players depicted on the same map
there was no real hint of that kind of
multiplayer component to adhere do you
think we're gonna see that maybe later
at Ubisoft press conference or yeah I
reckon so yeah I I am almost positive of
that so all right well we're looking
forward to that we're going to have a
pre-show for that in just a little while
also they showed off a rainbow 6 siege
yeah brief look at that which is coming
out later this year they showed off
maybe a new mode there was some some
bomb defusing stuff but only a glimpse
at the two maps we've seen thus far the
airplane of course and the house and
really a look you know I've played this
game I a bunch during the the alpha the
distinct operator
really really contribute to what sort of
each match feels like in which wow it's
going to play out they didn't really
make a point of showing off new
operators that kind of granularity stuff
maybe seems more suited for their
Prescott yes I really so known so there
was gonna be some other rainbow six
games that come with it right
imagination yeah so I think they're very
much trying to draw the comparison
between this game and the kind of like
working together cooperative kind of
thing and the rainbow six vegas games
which were huge on that with terrorist
hunt and kind of how difficult they were
to play if you weren't working together
so yeah this that those two games will
be coming with this with rainbow 6 siege
on xbox one I believe I I don't believe
it was going to be the same everywhere
so I think this might be a Microsoft
only deal well they made a point of
saying it's with the new backwards
compatibility thing that they're coming
so it's probably it's going to be
download codes and it's going to be that
same kind of code that you yeah you know
work in the same way than the backwards
compatibility they announced earlier in
the press conference would work as well
Rainbow six siege coming out October
13th and for more on siege and the
division we're going to look to our
Ubisoft press conference later today
then we had a quick announcement of
after that we had two quick gigantic
showed up on stage and this is now this
is the question I have for you guys what
is the name of this genre gigantic
overwatch battleborn battle cry they all
are slightly different but they're all
sort of hero combat yeah action-oriented
combat the term the term MOBA sort of it
like hangs in there game design somewhat
yeah I think they're closer to like
team-based first-person shooters like I
think of gigantic close being closer to
Team Fortress then a traditional mobile
game obviously it's cribbing a lot of
elements and well not a lot of likely he
kind of the hero elements of it and
putting it back into a team fortress
style blueprint I mean it doesn't have
mobs and creeps and that kind of thing
which are kind of at the heart of
mobiles right yeah so I think that's
what distinguishes it from a classic
MOBA so this is more like a a team
fortress with a twist i reckon and it
looks really really cool i mean gameplay
wise it looks fairly similar the classes
seem to be very very much like the
traditional classes you'd get in
something like team fortress but like
the characters
lines are really really cool I like the
look of the kind of the masked guy and
the arrow and bow and arrow character
which is Connie's little what like
broccoli demon broccoli the middle
school dragon I think I described it
during the conference conference as like
Pokemon meets team fortress where you
can like throw out this one monster to
do your bidding for a little while and
then just call it away we can't readily
summon them from like specific points in
that yeah it's really cool I like the
style of it right it looks really nice
and so a few other stories here free to
play oh yeah and across Windows 10 and
Xbox one of course with that Windows 10
integration there is the possibility for
cross-platform play I think gigantic is
one of the first games confirmed to have
that and that's going to be available
there's gonna be a beta for gigantic in
August and it's exclusive to the pc and
xbox one next up in the microsoft press
conference at e3 2015 was the indie
montage oh wow and man did they just
like blow through about a dozen or so
games really quick I had a bad moment
during that where I was like oh that's
cool that looks cool okay what's that
one that looks neat uh but then thinking
like oh my god they're just gonna blow
through this and not show us in depth
anymore fortunately my fears were
allayed when they did get into a sort of
a bunch of sort of highlighted indie
titles the first of which was Tacoma
from full right and at the fulbright of
course the folks who made gone home
tacoma one of the sort of eerie sort of
exploration type games a little bit in
the spirit of gone home but definitely a
different setting yeah I mean fulbright
absolutely fantastic studio that they
opened up the the montage there were
there for studios whether that what
they're on stage the eagle-eyed among
you at home will know that that's only
the same thing two years ago at lady
three shows shirt had like eight indie
developers get one stage and talk about
their timed exclusive games and I
thought you know Chris charla
introducing these four different games
that going to be exclusive or timed
exclusive to Xbox one that was super
smart I'm curious hear about this though
be at the very end yeah the thing is I
don't know american sign language so i
might be very
I don't want to step on anybody's toes
but it looks like she's she's using ASL
or something similar she's
fingerspelling so my question is you
know is is that in gameplay or are we
dealing with you know in this case a you
know a deaf protagonist we get really
interesting yeah it's especially in
light of an indie game they showed a few
demos later beyond eyes which the
creator or representative who was up on
stage described as wanted to capture the
experiance kind of of being blind this
is a blind protagonist and so she
explores her world with other senses and
her world is illuminated in a different
way a very kind of watercolor paint
early way yeah I which really I mean
shows beautifully and reminded me a sort
of echoes of Orion the blind forests
hearing at last year's Prescott reminded
me of the unfinished Swan as well a
little bit barrel yeah like a watercolor
version of that looks absolutely
beautiful it is yeah it looks really
nice so that was one another beyond eyes
another one of the indie games showcase
at microsoft's e3 press conference ashen
was another and that was the sort of uh
looked like an exploration game you were
a person to characters who had blank
faces and so I mean this shot is just
lovely and evocative of sort of
exploring the ruins of something long
past or of a different scale and
unfathomable sort of thing but then in
like just a minute or two you're like
okay cool this is like a co-op game is
to totally exit yeah he gets he gets
skewered pretty high a spear but here we
see some sort of yo are tropes uh what
do you think Kevin you look ashen
intriguing you in it it doesn't treat me
I just just because I love the
atmosphere I mean what I'm looking at
this the first thing I think of is is uh
echo echo from you know from tamika so
that's the vibe that I had it first and
then suddenly everything started
changing and it's like um this isn't
gonna go so well and ouch yeah yeah so
I'm sort of curious about what this
place is some you know that this ruin
where maybe they've awakened these these
robots yeah and it's not every game demo
that shows you the death of one person
that you presumed to be the protagonist
exactly of during the demo
but there you have a shin and then like
rounding out that Indy segment was one
that we are all just going bonkers or
here cuphead man you can't look at this
thing connection and not have a smile on
your face oh she's charming it's not
like utiful isn't it yeah it's just a
little okay you can't look at this game
without smiling it looks incredible
there's nothing quite like it out there
and why were you look about is
mechanically I space it's really just
look at em up really yeah yeah yeah what
we also said platformer right yeah
definitely want cuz well yeah you are
shooting but yeah a lot of it is
avoiding these sort of yeah complicated
projectiles coming your way it does yeah
points it just looks like you're playing
a cute version of a Carew go like like
hey look at this yeah having to dodge in
between fireballs while they covering
the knife and just looks so good like
it's gonna smell so hard yeah what was
the release date announced it was theirs
I 1963 plus 25 36 yeah 80 years so
coming down next year next 18 but based
on that old timey 1930s cartoon
aesthetic that's cop head rounding out
Microsoft's indie showcase at the
microsoft press conference here at e3
then moving right along we got to uh
Xbox game preview yeah Xbox game preview
Microsoft debuted here it's their
version of steam early access yeah are
you glad to see something like this come
to consoles yeah and I think it's pretty
cool people some people want to play
games early and they can I think I think
they're taking some of the danger away
from it by allowing people to trial a
game before they decide whether they
want to commit and be a part of that
early development process or not that's
really really small because a lot of the
dangers of steam early access is buying
into a game which seems okay and then
finding out it's actually complete crap
anyway boys yeah what vibe aw dang it
but like hinterland and Lily dangerous
are available today on the program so
you can go and check it out and see if
you if you want to play them and
commit money to it and go for it you
certainly can yep now let's talk about
the thing that got us all the most
excited I feel that I there's no
reservation and saying this was like my
most thrilling moment of e3 thus far the
hololens demo of Minecraft Oh Milo wow
wow red of yep I mean so we were talking
before the show about how hololens sort
of has the advantage on VR because you
can rig up a special camera and then see
it in action and the this table we see
here is where he sort of transfers the
game to and we're seeing it in action
and I still didn't want to believe it I
want yeah you're out like what is the
trick here yeah how are they faking this
but Justin hey Walt our senior news
producer here was saying yeah this is
negated yeah that's what it looks like
it is incredibly immersive yet and I
mean is this is this basically what you
like what you even even though Justin
has said it looks so I still can't
believe it like it's it it looks
incredible like the way he's just moving
into the actual like the the composition
of the image and just looking around it
looks it looks insane I don't know how
they're doing it which is kind of the
best thing you can say about it just
feels like magic is actually right i
mean if it's anything like this i'm
gonna have together yeah it's just like
and the best thing is like like we were
saying earlier it's it's just completely
different from normal vr yeah it's just
so different oh my God look at oh my god
I've not played much minecraft but man I
am looking forward to pounce on a play
minecraft I'm like I don't wake up now I
want to play them down for some
minecraft open my fingers around doing
this stuff yeah and it's just I mean
mine could they pick a debt a better
game to demo exactly minecraft is just
sort the spirit of Play and exploration
and it's laid out there right in front
of you and that's really what you want
when I think when you have a new piece
of gear like hololens you want it to be
something that people are excited to
play to explore in and to just kind of
mess around with and this kind of
sandbox experience of minecraft the way
that they've kept the sort of calibrated
it just I'm just thinking about all the
stories how much positive praise and
press they got in the early days of
Minecraft for being like a really
interesting and intuitive tool for kids
to learn things like engineering
and that kind of thing building Lee all
elevators and that kind of stuff and
then seeing this and just thinking man
they've just taken that to a whole new
level they could have this like in our
classrooms and that kind of thing which
is anything that's the exciting thing
this was just one demonstration of what
you could create yeah like with this
tool but like people are gonna create
these incredible Creek these weird
idiosyncratic yeah creation I mean you
would easily give this to like surgeons
and get them to do like trial runs on
surgeries and that kind of thing like
the applications of it now I just
mind-blowing it's obviously we're just
gonna play minecraft with it because
we're not that smart it's really I mean
it's like because this is so believably
awesome it really I'm thinking as you
guys are describing other applications
of the trailer they show yeah and it's
like I'm building them I'm designing a
motorcycle I'm doing a powerpoint
presentation I'm doing all this stuff
like it makes me a believer that that
stuff could work yeah and you yeah work
well because this works so well I want
it to work as well yeah oh my goodness
yeah whatever they want to believe
believe in hololens fascinating look at
microsoft's hololens playing minecraft
at microsoft's press conference here at
e3 2015 and then of course Microsoft
closed out their press conference with
one of their big franchise we all knew
was going to come Gears of War they said
Gears of War Ultimate Edition it's the
original gears remastered modernized
coming out on august twenty fifth but
its gears of war for that we saw the
longer demo he is full they've dropped
re overall very cool there's no war
happening it's just kids four of them
years for and it starts off and it's a
guy we don't really recognize in a dark
place and then he's with a woman they
are are they the new markets and um yeah
raucous and Anya marcussen Tonya yeah
but I was playable right from the get ya
took till gears of war 3 4 on yet ya
feel true uh but here we are it's very
dark right there we see there are two
moons and so I did a little googling and
then and according to Gears pedia there
Sarah the planet the gears ticking years
of war takes place on has only one moon
so this is our know this could be a new
planet well obviously they share some
technology we can see see the chainsaws
will answer this shotgun I'm panache
sure on his back looking at very
familiar yeah it looks it looks really
really cool I love
I'm just having flashbacks to playing
the first two kids games in coop and I'm
just so excited about it now I never
realized how much I care about gears
until right now ligo seeing it again be
like man I remember having so much fun
with gears I'm looking forward to seeing
more of it now and I mean expanded
fiction sure why not this is a talent
chance for them to actually try and tell
a better story I mean the first gears
game had of the bunch had the most
interesting story of it because it was
laying out a universe and this is an
elephant of being the origin yeah
exactly and if they treat this in a
similar fashion where they reset
everything and kind of draw a line
underneath all the other stuff that
happened before until a new gears story
it could be an opportunity to like go
back to their first arrow the first game
and have an interesting story to tell is
that don't touch that these Orleans over
it's like like his face uh in terms of
you know knew you were talking about new
fiction we also see new enemies so
perhaps instead of you know the emulsion
inside the planet making low ratios made
these creepy like more insectile enemies
yeah right at the end yeah i mean the
enemies that we saw like a tougher when
they first popped up i was like wow it
looks like Rex from Mass Effect it's
yeah like I just want to hear the gear
just I like crow good shooting as it's
coming towards the heart miss right yeah
and wives and respect we're in the same
you know baby looks just like Rex oh
except now except now yeah and the main
character every time he looks just like
BJ + Co it's a bit like remember people
made the observation that wow it looks
like pj but yeah i like the UI looks
similar so it's kind of evoking the same
or old Gears of War kind of familiar
feeling graphically it looks fantastic
oh yeah looks I mean the kids games are
always stunning to look at and
chainsawing things is still red
apparently yeah as you can see how are
you guys sad to not see doom style
dismemberment out of these chains oh no
I'm okay I'm okay way we're all right
with it oh and with that tongue party in
the gears of war got years for guys face
we're gonna wrap up here our post-show
coverage from Microsoft press conference
2015 at e3 we are going to be coming
back at you in
just a short amount of time let me check
the schedule here because we have got
the e a press conference coming up at
twelve-thirty thats in just 45 minutes
we'll be back with the pre-show and so
please come join us then get some food
or whatever meal time it is for you
right now we're going to go eat we'll be
back to talk about EA ear live from
gamespot HQ at e3 2015